dann wollen wir heute mit örtlichen
feuerwehren zusammenarbeiten wir wollen
hat ihr verfahren und taktischen abläufe
volieren geht stramm
gesamt den konkreten sind es 32 blöcke
hubschrauber eine arbeits und drei
hubschrauber baby
[Musik]
wir haben heute unsere jährliche landes
flugdienst übung des niedersächsischen
landesfeuerwehrverbandes in
zusammenarbeit mit dem deutschen
bundesheer und mit der polizei sind hier
in niederösterreich in bezüglich
entfällt also in türnitz hier werden wir
heute einen waldbrand simulieren im
bereich des opel-werks der im schweren
gelände schwer zugänglich ist wir werden
auch hier erstmalig sda unsere neuen
wald brandbekämpfer wir haben ja 400 man
ausgebildet teilweise in portugal
die werden heute erstmalig hier auch in
so quasi realeinsatz bei dieser übung
gehen die übung selbst da ist ja gut
koordiniert die zusammenarbeit mit dem
hubschrauber des bundesheeres aber auch
der polizei funktioniert sehr gut
wir werden hier mit unseren lösch
behältern und zwischenwasser die bos wir
eine optimale versorgung amberg machen
und von dort aus den brand dann
effizient zu bekämpfen
[Musik]
heute gemeinsam szenarien feuer werden
aber mit dem roten kreuz und andere
organisationen
das österreichische bundesheer trainiert
jedes jahr hier in niederösterreich mit
nahezu allen ein sensation
auch im flugdienst weil ich ganz
entscheidend ist dass wir das üben was
ihren einsätzen brauchen gerade
waldbrand ist eine thematik zukunft
waldbrände finden des öfteren start des
bundesheer ist hier im assistenzeinsatz
und für uns ganz ganz wichtig dass die
verfahren und die abläufe
dementsprechend geübt werden das sehen
wir heute zusätzliche anzumerken
das österreichische bundesheer heute in
niederösterreich mit über 400 soldaten
soldaten im assistenzeinsatz ist und die
dementsprechende gesundheitsbehörde zu
unterstützen wir in niederösterreich
bezeichnen das zusammenarbeiten der
verschiedenen einsatzorganisationen als
die sicherheits familie niederösterreich
die unterführung unser landeshauptmann
stellvertreters der auch heute hier ist
und auch mit den anderen kommandanten
hier ein entscheidungsgremium war bildet
um hierfür die landeshauptleute dem
entspreche entscheidungen oft zu
bewerten
[Musik]
mein name ist maler alexander b vom
dienstgrad herr wachtmeister 70
blackboard techniker und arbeiter die
aufgabe den 7 3000 feuerwehr stübel zu
bedienen
das ganze funktioniert mit diesem
bedienelement wir haben zwei arten des
auslösers einmal können wir sprühen
dann haben wir innerhalb von 30 sekunden
können wir 3000 liter wasser über dem
brandherd sprühen und einmal können wir
voll auslasten
dann wäre es in 30 kunden wären 3000
liter wasser versprüht
[Musik]
die große herausforderung bei dieser
übung war natürlich für uns die
kostenlast fliegen das ist mit dem der
schweren bahn ticket und label
wegzukommen und oben die brandstelle zu
benetzen das ist relativ aufwendig und
leistungsgerechte
[Musik]